[Music]
[Applause]
Jesus Christ I'll tell you I flew here
on Air Canada I wish it was a
Sky balloon because that's the airline
stinks
yeah
I assumeburg gets around in that seems
like her mode of transportation doesn't
it yeah you know she's uh she's 20. I
always thought she was like nine
I had no idea she's so youthful man
autism don't crack
good for her I mean hey I'm an Asperger
too I can say that
I'm Brady yeah yeah well he just retired
finally you know yeah he just uh he got
dumped by jizz yeah
I got a big thing going you know he's a
great player Tom Brady always says like
the covid of football you know he's
thriving in Florida he put up some big
numbers and a lot of people never
believed in him
I'm too irish guys all right yeah I love
the Irish you know why the Irish are
great because they're one of the last
groups you can on and you guys
never can play
I mean think about all the Irish terms
it's like uh Irish coffee that's just
coffee with booze in it you know or
Irish goodbye that's where you get too
drunk and forget to say bye or I'm gonna
beat you like a redhead stepchild no one
says they're Irish but we know what the
going on there yeah
and they keep changing all these team
names like the the Indians or the
guardians or the Redskins or the
commanders you ever see the fight in
Irish it's a drunk with
his hat ready to go
nobody
you guys are tough you never complain
and you know you guys are called the
they call me the n-words of Europe and
if you rearrange the letters in ginger
all right
there you go Irish
Dana White oh Dana White he slapped the
out of his wife yeah that's right
I love the guys like hey she hit him
first you know he's a feminist you know
what the the Dana White slap he hit his
wife I wish Rogan was there to go
[Applause]
wouldn't that be fun was there a ding
was Herb Dean there like all right all
right all right that's enough that's
enough
I know he's not a fighter but these
fighter guys they tend to hit their
wives a lot I think as they fight all
day they just go home they're like oh
sorry I gotta keep working you know
like look I'm a comedian I go home I
make jokes to my wife she's like could
you turn it off and I'm like oh okay now
I'm maybe I will hit you but uh
Miami what a town I love it here fun
people
been here three days I'm think I'm gonna
get lip injections and to come Cuban
I love Florida something about this
state you know right when I land I just
want a guy's wife
there's something in the air here you
just want to do meth off a gay guy's ass
you know
ah
wild out here I feel so free the state
flag of Florida should be fake tits a
handgun and a coked up iguana on a jet
ski yeah
foreign
no I can't lose this baby this is all I
got yeah yeah
[Applause]
oh yeah there's about eight good minutes
in there baby look at that
oh that's like an old pirate treasure
map right there
yeah you know what this is actually a
Biden's hidden files right here I got in
my pocket yeah
[Applause]
oh yeah my back is not doing well but uh
you know it's from all the anal I
received but yeah fondue yeah that was
my ex-girlfriend she was Asian fondue
clip it
you talk about the documents yes yes yes
I heard they were written by Chad gbt
Avatar Two yeah they spent more money on
that than Ukraine
Andrew Tate uh-huh well he just got into
it with Greta thunber you see that she
accused him of sex trafficking and you
know she hates traffic
colonoscopy all right you got to do that
when you're 40 right well it depends on
what you got oh all right well I
got AIDS uh I don't know what to do all
right I got a pretty wide I
think I'll be all right with the camera
I mean you could get a full
I gotta do kegels all right
I can do that I got a really strong
like if I have a turd that I
can't get out I can cigar snip it with
my pretty impressive
oh yeah I could circumcise a kid with my
I'm pretty sure
foreign
if I had to do it I could do it
old tight ass old Norman over here
that's what they used to call me in
college
yes sir y'all need to jump on black
Instagram and Twitter it's more fun oh
black Twitter is amazing and uh Hood
Clips oh yeah you can't I
start
um I'm following a lot of white girls
because it was too many pink
organization Amazon
um box reveals for me it's like and they
always got miniature white girls
love little titty tell me about it
it's a problem I think somebody's gonna
bring up the squirrel in the
room
thank you
I mean are we gonna talk about this
sir you've been waiting for this all
night haven't you
a front row seat
what's that
no you've soaked up enough attention
with the rodent on your head can
you come on stage no
squirrel found its nut I'll tell you
that right now
God damn it the name's Garfield
you were bred for this
Garfield well sir
you hate Mondays and I hate you
well I'm starting to think coven started
with you yeah
not the Chinese thing just the
squirrel
is that thing real
yeah is it oh my God I bet you killed
the class pet when you were younger
didn't you and you kept it you stuffed
it and you put it on your weird hat you
know the Hat was already atrocious but
you had to put a dead
animal on top of it all right
it bothers me that you probably get laid
a lot too which is uh
a little off-putting
okay boy Peta if they catch you they're
gonna really beat the out of you
yeah it's tough out there I'm seeing
somebody now but boy single life yeah
that's that's the real deal you know
people are so condescending to single
people they go you're single oh
don't get lonely
like well sure but how come we always
assume loneliness is worse than a
relationship
I feel like loneliness a lot easier to
manage definitely to get out of you get
lonely call a friend go to a movie if
you're in a barrel issue if you're like
well I guess I got a killer
or him or him
my ex she was tough my ex was like a
real big feminist now I'm a feminist but
she was like annoying yeah
yeah she would always say stuff like men
just should win by their looks it's all
about her looks what about our
achievements which is true men do do
that but ladies you do it too we all
judge women
all right
like one time she helped me flirt
another girl and she was like what does
she look like that was the first
question I was like whoa what about her
achievements
she's a human being goddammit
[Music]